the second second victim initials are L
was involved in an incident which
occurred between September 26 1998 and
September 25th 2001 a grand jury
returned an indictment on two counts of
aggravated criminal sexual abuse based
on the victims being under the age of 17
and Robert Kelly being more than five
years older than that victim the third
victim initials LC was involved in an
incident which occurred February 18th
2003 a grand jury returned an indictment
on one count of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse based on the transmission
of semen by Robert Kelly upon any part
of the body of the victim for the
purpose of sexual gratification during
the course of an underlying felony of
attempt criminal sexual assault the
fourth victim initials JP was involved
in incidents which occurred between May
1st 2009 and January 31st 2010 a grand
jury returned an indictment on the three
counts three counts of aggravated
criminal sexual abuse based on the
victim being under the age of 17 and
Robert Kelly being more than five years
older than the victim aggravated
criminal sexual abuse is a class 2
felony with the sentencing range of 3 to
7 years per count it is also probation
of all we anticipate that mr. Kelly will
appear in bond court tomorrow afternoon